[Music]
tom is with us to start us off in grand
rapids michigan hey
tom welcome to the dave ramsey show hey
dave hey chris thanks for checking my
call
sure what's up hey so uh
my wife and i are about to close on our
second home
um we're about 25 i'm 25 she's 26
we have enough between cash and
investments to
pay uh for the whole home in cash
the problem is a lot of it is in
investments
and a lot of it about half of it was put
in
around april and so we're looking at
paying potentially short-term or
long-term capital gains in a couple
months if we were to take it out
and we're kind of just like it's gotten
to a large number and
the amount of money that you know i
could be potentially making year over
year
just you know and study growth being in
good mutual funds
i'm weary about taking that large amount
of money out
um and not just continuing to let it
grow and especially since the mortgage
rate is so low
tom how much money were you talking
about you're saying a large amount give
us give us some specifics
yeah so i got about 160 000 in cash and
i have about 430 000
investments and what's the basis on that
430
uh what do you mean what'd you pay for
it uh so i have about
245 000 in actual cash
that wasn't put in no no that's what you
put in to make 400
yeah so you got 200 000 gain in in
nine nine months yep okay
all right and so yeah you're going to
pay ordinary income on that so that's
going to be pretty heavy
pretty hefty all right so that that's
question one
um and then the overarching question is
uh
do i pay six hundred thousand dollars
for a house and pay cash because
mortgage rates are lower
yeah the i mean it's it's 535 000 is the
home cost
um and so uh you know i i
my thought is is we're both maxing out
our 401ks uh we make just a little over
200 000 a year
and you know we could just divert you
know roughly
60 000 a year for the next six years or
so or
you know after the 20 down six seven
years and just do it that way
rather than you know emptying all of our
investments and stuff and you know
paying cash it's the only debt we would
have
right let's let's let's pan back just a
little bit because there's two or three
different
answers uh and it's it's the nuances of
it
okay number one where do we want to end
up 10 years from now let's pan back that
far a hundred percent of the time
all of the data that we find i mean is
it
100 of the time you're going to want to
be debt-free right 10 years from today
okay or seven years from today or as you
said six years from today
all right so the long-term goal is
debt-free now why is that
well it adds stabilization to your
overall life and
and that you own your home there's no
threats when there's a pandemic that
something turns upside down on your
wonderful
careers that you have and all of a
sudden this house is in jeopardy and
everything's in jeopardy and there's a
lot of stress
so if you're the third pig that built
his house on the brick
with the big bad wolf comes along and
the brick is paid for you got no issue
that's right so that's where we want to
end up and we know from all our data
that the millionaires want to do that
and we know the borrower really is slave
to the lender that's not a dead gum joke
and so that's where we want to end up so
in light of that
i figured out i don't borrow money ever
for anything
and so i would be looking at a delayed
closing on this to get me past the
capital gains date
so i wouldn't close on this property
until april and i'd actually pay them a
little extra to do that if it's me
because i'm gonna pay a hundred percent
cash a hundred percent of the time
now the one thing we don't yell at
people for is taking out a mortgage if
they can pay it off rather quickly
uh or as quickly as possible and so we
wouldn't yell at you if you took out a
short-term bank loan and paid it off
within a year
to avoid the to make that a long-term
capital gain instead of an ordinary gain
which is going to cut your tax bill in
half
that's a 30 or a 40 000 play in this
scenario
right tax savings only now am i going to
keep you
in debt on your house because of low
mortgage rates
in order to invest more absolutely not
as a philosophy absolutely not so that's
not where i want you to be long-term
it's not where i want you to be as soon
as you can get there
so there's two or three things playing
in this but the capital gains thing
and the eighth grade the april date and
the game you know you take a
ordinary income on a 200 000 gain or 250
000 gain
versus a 15 uh which is what you'd be on
your long term capital after one year
yeah i'm probably going to want you to
mess with that i can't
because i have vowed before god i will
never borrow money again
for any reason because i truly believe
the teach stuff we teach
so in if i were in your shoes and i'm
sweating that capital gain i'm going to
just do a delayed closing in order to
avoid it
and get it past that one year mark and
come out of there but tom
you know you're really kind of asking
two questions the the capital gains
thing and the gains that you've had this
year
right have made you a little greedy
because you had an unrealistically good
year on the stock market
it is unrealistic it was a wonderful
year especially when you bought at the
bottom that's right
absolutely right at the bottom and tom
i'm going to tell you this
25 and 26 years old calling in with this
kind of question
and the path you all are on you've got
the habit of saving you've got the habit
of being intentional
please please please continue to grow
that skill uh do not backslide and i
know that because having been 25 and 26
stupid comes around and it's shiny and
it's real easy
if you're not clear on what it is you
want to make some bad decisions so
very proud of the progress you're making
take your time look at this
and it's okay to delay some
gratification because it's going to feel
a whole lot better later when you walk
in that home and it's all yours
yeah the number of times i couldn't
do something because i didn't have the
money right then
and so because i refuse to borrow money
because i truly believe the borrower's
slave of the lender i really am a
legalist
i really am a fanatic i really don't
borrow money
for anything but the number of times i
couldn't do something so i didn't
because i couldn't figure out a way to
do it i couldn't scheme it i couldn't
scam it
i end up with a better deal like let's
say
he said okay i can't do this if i'm not
going to do a delayed closing
because i'm unwilling to pay the capital
gains and i'm unwilling to borrow money
right okay and so we're going and then
the the seller says no won't do it late
closing
you lose the deal yeah you know what you
end up with better house later
every time you get an upgrade wow god's
always standing there with an upgrade
the other side of you making the right
decision and that's not what our mind
tells us no
no it's our mind we have a shortage a
scarcity
mentality that if you don't do this
you're never
ever going to be able to do it the
number of times i've walked away with a
deal
and when i walk around the corner
there's a better one waiting
because i walked away from the deal for
the right reasons wow
i'm gonna dance with the girl that
brought me that's right i mean this
debt-free thing
it brought me here it's real this you
know investing thing it brought me here
this outrageous generosity thing
it brought me here and i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna i don't care if there's
another pretty girl to party
those are the ones that i came with
that's a girl i came with you know i'm
dancing with her that's it